hi guys I I just wanted to say thank you
guys so much for all of the love that
you've shown since I posted that
late-night vlog I woke up this morning
and I literally rolled over open my
phone and I just saw like an ungodly
number of notifications just with with
understanding and love and sharing and
and it was it was just a non-stop parade
of support and and I can't even describe
to you like how good that was for me at
the moment because I didn't know the
response evety was going to get I really
didn't I was just putting my feelings
out there because I couldn't keep
bottling them up like that and I didn't
know if it was going to come across as
like whining like boohoo oh I have so
much success it's it's such a pain to
have all these opportunities laid out
before me like I think looking to come
across that way and I I'm really happy
that that people understood that and and
thank you thank you for I've spent all
morning reading messages and reading
comments and reading everything that you
guys have put out there there's many
pieces of fan art that are being made in
support of it and I just wanted to say
like before I before I like move on to
other silly Let's Plays that I have
planned for today which I do have a lot
and there's a really silly video in the
pipeline but I didn't want to I didn't
want to bowl over all of those like all
those really important emotions that
came out overnight and if you haven't
seen the video yet get ready for a big
blubbering baby markiplier because
that's what I'm doing but I just I had
to stop and thank you guys
I had to before I moved on to anything
else I had to and I don't want you guys
to worry I'll try to keep this short and
sweet because I've said enough of what I
said but I I don't want you guys to
worry about me and how I'm doing and
where I'm going because number one I'm
not quitting YouTube like I've been
doing this for five years and that may
seem like a long time but that's
actually not a long time that's that's
like undergrad
you know that that's enough to get a
college degree and once you get that
college degree and once you've learned
and spent all that time doing the theory
of it when you step out of those doors
into the real world you find out you
don't know nearly as much as you thought
you did but that's not what worries me I
don't want people to think that I'm
afraid of taking the next step in going
like even farther than I am like simpler
than I am now because like that doesn't
scare me like knowing the future has
different opportunities and challenges
that doesn't scare me at all
that excite me that excites me I just
can't wait to go out there and find out
what I'm good at and what I'm bad at
like I just can't wait to fail I just
can't wait to fall flat on my face I
just can't wait to see how far I go and
then immediately fall down and then get
back up and just prove people wrong like
god I love that I love failing because
it just gives me an idea of how much
farther I need to go and it gives me an
idea of what the road is leading to and
that is what I love like I love that I
love seeing those challenges I love
meeting them I love showing people what
I can do because I mean that's what it's
all been about when I say that at the
beginning of my YouTube channel I was
only looking up it's because I could
only look up I was at rock bottom there
was no down and if there was a down I
didn't want to see it so the only way to
go forward was just to keep doing it
every day because every day was better
than the last day because every day new
people were coming in and seeing my
stuff and I get to meet them and show
them who I was
and and at the same time discover who I
am look I didn't know who I was back
then I don't fully understand myself now
like I don't and that again that doesn't
scare me look I know I'm discovering new
things about myself everyday and I'm and
I'm growing as a person and I'm learning
things and as you guys are watching me
you're growing too and you were learning
and what I say does influence you and
what you say does influence me like a
beautiful thing about YouTube is that
it's a two-way street like I learned
from you and you learn from me and then
in that circle as we discover who we
really are and that's a never ending
journey like beyond the five years that
I've been doing YouTube and into the
five years that I'll keep doing YouTube
and do other big projects like I'll
still be figuring out who I am and I
really hope that doesn't scare anybody
because I don't know what I want to do
like I don't know what I want to
dedicate my time to fully and I know
that I can't dedicate my time to
everything I know that and I accept that
and I understand but I think that going
into the future so long as I understand
is that each day can be better in the
last day and so long as I can keep
moving forward I make sure all worth it
that makes you one big beautiful journey
and the end of the road isn't important
where I end up isn't important because
I'm never gonna stop moving not until
the day I die I'm not gonna stop moving
and I think that's a beautiful thing and
it's even more beautiful kept like I can
be honest with you guys about my fears
and apprehensions and I can be open with
you about that and you can be open with
me about that too like that's just
amazing so anyway I said I'd keep this
short and sweet
still got blabber E but it's okay
because I'm not gonna stop I'm not going
to stop being blabbering I'm not I'm
gonna keep doing it
so just thank you guys thank you for
being here with me on this crazy journey
thank you for trusting me in knowing
where I'm going which I don't but that's
okay
because I'm always going to keep trying
to steer all of us in the right
direction so thank you everybody so much
for watching and thank you for all the
love share that love with everybody you
see today spread it around and oh and
let's do a charity livestream tomorrow
how about that I'll be pretty cool about
10 a.m. some good Pacific time yeah
we'll do it so thank you everybody so
much for watching the silliness will
returned and normal Let's Plays will
continue as per scheduled and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye